my mentor under addiction is not why the
addiction but why the pain if you want
to look at what causes addiction you
have to look at the benefit of addiction
what did it do for you people say
typically it gave me pain relief escape
from stress it gave me a sense of
connection a sense of belonging
the addiction met some essential human
need that otherwise wasn't met in that
person's life so all of these states of
lacking connection or being isolated of
having pain very too much stress in your
life
these are straits of emotional pain and
when you look at populations of addicts
what you find is that the more adversity
in childhood exponentially the greater
the risk of addiction which doesn't mean
that every person traumatized will
become an addict but it does mean that
every addict was traumatized in my
opinion addiction is manifested in any
behavior but a person finds temporary
pleasure or relief in but suffers
negative consequences as a result out
and does not give up or cannot give up
despite those negative consequences
tobacco alcohol substances of all kinds
it could also be related to sex gambling
shopping eating work virtually any area
of human activity can become addictive
depending on the person's relationship
to it I had two major addictions in my
life and one was to work and I also an
addiction to shopping in my case for
classical music CDs one day I spent
$8,000 on compact discs it doesn't
matter how many sets of a particular
composer symphonies you already have you
have to get the next one and the next
one in the grip of the shopping fever I
once left patient and labor
and actually went downtown to get this
and I missed a delivery
that's how impactful it was know you may
think that's laughable
how can you compare your addiction to
those of your heroin addicted patients
my own addicted patients when I told
them about my addictions they didn't
laugh or they shook their heads and I
said yeah doc we get it you're just like
the rest of us well the point is that
we're all just like the rest of us the
greatest myths and addiction number one
that is genetic it does run in families
but why does it run in families if I'm
an alcoholic and if I yelled and scream
at my kids and then they do go up to
soothe themselves with alcohol did I
pass that on to them genetically or is
that a behavior they developed because I
recreated the same conditions that I
grew up in there might be genetic
predispositions but a predisposition is
not the same as a predetermination the
other myth around addiction is that it's
a choice that people make and the whole
legal system is based on the idea that
people are choosing to the Attic let's
punish them for it so as to deter others
addiction is not a choice anybody makes
it's a response to emotional pain the
other myth is that addiction is
restricted to the substance user or to a
few losers in our society it's rife and
rampant through our culture you would
think that with the utter failure of
most treatment modalities when it comes
to addiction we would wake up and ask
ourselves do we really understand its
condition but that doesn't seem to
happen we're not looking at its real
nature as a response to human suffering
because really not helping people work
through and resolve their traumas so we
keep saying what's wrong with you
instead of asking what happened to you
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon